film length a fifth NBA championship  would represent what I think if you had  any doubt it's just no more doubt but I  already feel like the doubt is gone it's  gone the team that will give the  Warriors the most problems this season  is the Brooklyn Nets they can shoot they  can defend they can play in the half  court they can play in transition they  got the pieces player you hate matching  up against the most is Darius Garland I  hate Garden DG I'll guard them and I'ma  always sit on the garden I'm never not  I'm never ducking no switch another  Grizzlies Warriors playoff would be  another Warriors win this year's MVP  will be it's probably Joker again what  if you were not an NBA player you'd be  possibly a director directing people as  one of my strengths though and so if I  can  learn that business I think I can apply  some things about leadership that I  already understand